today we're gonna take a deep look at
taxes and at the economy we're going to
talk about what should the top marginal
tax rate be will businesses leave the
country if we increase taxes on them
we'll talk about this thing called the
Laffer curve and how profits are
measured in complicated taxes we'll also
look at some very notable public
face-plants on the issue of taxation
where truth has sort of seeped through
the BS talking points that we often hear
and then we'll also talk about what is
good for the economy how do we measure
what is good for the economy important
topic as we were getting close to the
end of the year and very soon we will
all be doing our 2019 taxes remember
that on January 1st we are trying to
kick off 2020 an election year really
strongly will be offering a massive
obscene membership special to start 2020
be notified of it by email on January
1st simply by getting on our mailing
list at david pakman.com on the first
you will get an email from me telling
you if you've been waiting for a huge
discount this is the one to take
advantage of add your name to the
supporters of independent media in this
what will be an all-important election
year so make sure to sign up for our
newsletter at david pakman.com to be
notified let's get right into it today's
topic taxes and the economy
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
hey David there's a lot of discussion
about taxes wealth tax capital gains tax
income tax question can you just tell us
what you think the top marginal tax rate
should be yes I can I think it should be
between seventy and seventy three
percent now I am not suggesting that at
$500,000 a year in income where the
question that I have is at what income
level should a seventy percent marginal
tax rate kick in it shouldn't be after
you earn fifty thousand dollars
I don't believe it should be after you
earn a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars I don't believe it should be
once you're earning five hundred
thousand dollars I think that we should
get to 70 or seventy-three percent of
the overwhelming majority of the
research I've seen shows that if scaled
correctly topping out at 70 or
seventy-three generates the most
government revenue before you start
losing revenue because the tax is so
high that people start getting
disincentivized
from work so I've seen proposals that
kick in the seventy percent at a million
dollars a year of income I've seen
proposals that do it at two million
dollars a year of income or five million
dollars a year of income or ten million
dollars a year of income maybe ten
millions too high that really is a very
small percentage of the population but
there are two things to keep in mind one
it's the marginal tax rate below that
level of income wherever you said it you
are paying a lower rate and number two
there should be more rates between our
current top rate I believe the current
top rate is thirty seven percent there
needs to be more between 37 and seventy
if that were to be kicked in
so it would be graduated you might go
okay I think right now for 20 or 480
maybe is where 37% kicks in then you
might go to 45 between 480 and 750 or a
million then you might go to 52 between
a million and two million it's got a
scale and those are the models that
generate the most government revenue and
they are not so oppressive that they
start to disincentivize work in a way
that will be problematic for the economy
a lot of research on this I'm all
is up to having my mind changed on it
now there's other questions that are
ancillary to this that are important
ones like for example should capital
gains be taxed at that same rate right
now there's a lot of very wealthy people
who if they were to pay income tax as as
earned income as wages would be paying
37% but because they are receiving a lot
of this income through capital gains
whether its dividends or other sorts of
capital gains selling stocks that
they've made money on they are taxed at
the lower capital gains rates so one
idea that is often mentioned is in order
to eliminate that you really need to
raise the capital gains rate to simply
be what the Earned Income the the wage
rate would be personal income tax rate
so that there is no advantage to earning
the income via capital gains rather than
working for a living as some like to say
I'm open I'm open to raising I believe
capital gains should be raised but I
think you also need more levels
previously or right now I believe that
there's just two rates for capital gains
I think it should be progressive it
needs to have more tears than two and
I'm get I'm going from memory here I'm
just riffing but I do think that there
are more delicate considerations when
you raise capital gains I think it
should be done but I think we need to
understand that it is not the same as
raising taxes on wages but to go back to
the beginning
I believe the top marginal tax rate
should be seventy percent the debate is
at what level of income should that rate
kick in and I want to hear from you on
this issue we've got a fantastic bonus
show coming up for you today what is the
bonus show well every day we do an hour
show that show is available to everybody
it goes out on the radio it goes out on
TV it's the free podcast it gets chopped
up and uploaded to YouTube as video
clips but there is another show that we
do every day it's called the bonus show
and you can get access to it two ways
you can become a member at join
pakman.com it's very cheap it supports
the
work we do and you get instant access to
the bonus show or you can go to
patreon.com/scishow and make a pledge of
at least five dollars a month from five
dollars and up you get access to the
bonus show and then you will be able to
join us as a producer Pat will also be
doing on the bonus show Pat now also
hosting the Friday bonus show himself
much to the pleasure and dismay of
different people in the audience Pat
will talk to you very very shortly
next question today is from Lopez Lopez
says won't businesses just move to other
countries if we increase taxes on them
basically the answer is no not in any
statistically significant way this is a
very common canard that's floated by the
anti-tax right in the United States and
maybe also in Europe although I I follow
that less closely the idea here is if
you are a corporation and the government
increases your taxes you would be
incentivized to move your operation to
some other country that has a lower tax
rate there's a couple things that we
have to discuss there but let's start
with the sort of most basic I mean
American companies mostly are American
yes there are multinationals which
already are doing business all over the
world and they can more easily move
their headquarters if not all physical
presence but what you have to remember
is a lot of those companies have already
established all sorts of tax shelters
and havens so that's not going to
dramatically change if they've already
determined well we do better by having
an Irish headquarters but we still have
the American presence because we have
the United States such a major market
that is one reason why they are not
going to say we're gonna relinquish our
position in the United States altogether
the other thing you have to remember is
even though you might be able to avoid
some American business taxes if you move
your operation to another country then
you risk having added tariffs if you
still want to do business with American
consumers and corporations and that in
some cases may end up sort of zeroing
out the tax benefit but most importantly
all
but the biggest businesses are simply
not going to move to other countries if
you consider all small businesses and
even most medium-sized businesses that
operate primarily in the United States
if you have a huge roofing company or a
construction company not like a local
construction company but the big real
estate companies and you basically work
in the US why are you gonna move to
another country it doesn't make any
sense
it's logistically significant it's a
it's a logistically significant
undertaking and you're an American
company with American customers and all
American speaking American English
speaking employees so it's just not
practical to think that that's what
people are going to do now we actually
have some data where we can analyze this
because the same claim has been made for
a really long time about rich people
it's easier for a rich person to move to
another country or to a lower tax state
than it is for a huge company to move
from one country to another and it turns
out that millionaires don't move very
much
millionaires actually move way less than
poor people about half the rate only 2.4
percent of millionaires move in any
given year versus 4.5% of poorer
Americans and interestingly when
millionaires do decide to move they
slightly favor lower tax states slightly
many millionaires are moving to higher
tax states many millionaires move to the
states with the same level of tax and
some millionaires move to lower tax
states and for 85 percent of them the
tax rate in the state they are moving to
is not an important consideration if you
go from looking at millionaires to
looking at billionaires 84% of
billionaires live in their country of
birth period and there's no solid
evidence that tax rates are influencing
them in terms of where it is that they
want to live but here's the really
important part eighty four percent of
new billionaires live in their birth
country 16 percent of billionaires don't
live in their birth country but almost
all of them moved to that country before
they were billionaires mean
that if the tax rate was a consideration
it was a consideration in some vague
distant way if they ever are
billionaires they'd be better off in one
country versus another rather than I'm
moving now because I want to save money
on taxes so of course when you get to
the margins you have to consider if a
government puts ridiculously high taxes
on corporations it is going to serve as
more of an incentive to move country for
that reason what we're talking about in
the United States about eliminating
loopholes and write-offs and some of
these other mechanisms that exist for
corporations to end up paying almost no
taxes or sometimes no taxes or even
getting tax credits even though they
made profit for the most part these are
changes well within the sort of
reasonable that are not going to cause
those businesses to relocate I'm sure
you can find individual instances of
anything in a country of 330 million
people but from a macroeconomic level
it's been widely widely debunked all
right let's get into audience questions
for the week of course you can send them
in however you want email voicemail
Twitter reddit whatever you want today's
first question is via voicemail the
voicemail number is two one nine two
David P hey David I wanted to ask you
about the Laffer curve I hear a lot of
people on the Left often when putting
the idea of the Laffer curve because it
seems to be associated with Reaganomics
and the extent to which that it is you
know I can understand this kind of
criticism but I just want to hear from
you in theory why the idea is not sound
because my understanding of it is that
at a zero percent tax rate the
government will take in zero dollars in
revenue obviously at a hundred percent
tax rate the government will take in
zero percent revenue because it will
completely destroy any kind of
productivity so all to my mind the
Laffer curve says correct me if I'm
wrong is that there's just a number
somewhere in between 0 and 100 that's
optimal obviously people on the right
will tend to say that that's a lower
number and use this idea as a
justification
reduce tax rates but I don't understand
why in theory and liberals could very
easily apply the laboratory and say the
ideal tax rate is actually higher so I
don't understand why the Laffer curve is
kind of always associated with the
political right in this country when it
seems to me that it's sort of a neutral
thing that either side could use and it
seems like sort of a common-sense idea
so I'd like to hear your take on this
thank you yeah so listen the right uses
the Laffer curve because they like to
come up with just really simple ways of
doing politics like they've been really
successful by saying hey taxes or taxes
are bad because it's your money you've
earned it and you should get to keep it
so taxes should be really low or
abortion is bad because you're killing a
kid that's it and they really like these
simple ideas so the Laffer curve has
been used almost exclusively by the
right to justify cutting taxes you're
right it could hypothetically be used by
the left but it's not because the left
tends to take a more nuanced view on
this and I'll explain what I mean so yes
the Laffer curve is the idea that given
some tax rate between 0% and a hundred
percent there is some optimal optimal
number but more importantly and this is
where the right tends to use it they
often like to argue that a reduction in
the tax rate can lead to an increase in
government revenue that basically the
idea would be if you sometimes lower the
tax rate typically that's what the right
wants to do you will generate more total
revenue by more people working because
the tax rate on their income is lower
and because there will be more money
floating around for economic growth here
are the problems with the Laffer curve
number one it's usually used to justify
a reduction in taxes when actually an
increase in taxes would be better for
the economy so the Laffer curve is
constantly misused by the right but the
most important thing is that the tax
rate that the Laffer curve is referring
to is like an overall rate or an average
rate of some kind and as we know we have
a progressive tax system so the impact
that a chain
the tax rate is going to have on
government revenue is going to be very
different based on who is getting the
tax increase or the tax decrease you
could have a decrease or an increase to
the average tax rate in a way that would
be stimulative to the economy or not if
you give all if you decrease taxes by
reducing the tax rate only on the
richest Americans your economic benefit
is going to be far smaller than if you
lower the average tax rate by giving
money back to middle-class Americans
because middle-class Americans need the
extra money for their daily lives
whereas the very rich are just going to
save that money which is not very
economically stimulative so that's why
the right Pat likes to oversimplify a
lot of issues and they say hey the
Laffer curve tells us you lower taxes
revenue goes up the average tax rate
that the Laffer curve deals with does
not actually tell us anything about what
would happen to the economy which tax
bracket are you talking about yeah this
is what Republicans are trying to argue
now right with their tax plan yeah you
know even though revenues will go down
will make up for it because they'll be
so much more economic productivity
indeed but then you have independent
agencies analyzing it and they predict
maybe 1/10 of the economic output that
Republicans are predicting that's
exactly right
and you could have this is not what
people I think don't understand is we're
not making an argument for or against
raising or lowering taxes on any
particular tax bracket in this segment
what I'm telling you is that the Laffer
curve is effectively useless if we're
talking about the average tax rate
because we have a progressive tax system
in the u.s. with brackets and it's
almost always misused by the right just
to justify lowering taxes all the time
which is exactly what they want to do so
yes Laffer curve it's interesting it's
not particularly useful to us to in
thinking about what it is we need to do
with tax paul yeah I love it
zero to 100 percent somewhere in the
middle of there but it tells us nothing
about where the top of that parabola is
like where does it max out and not to
mention what the brackets should be and
at what income limits you go from from
being in one bracket the other which are
really the most important thing so it's
interesting to know about the Laffer
curve
know how much it's gonna teach you about
what taxes should be the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com let's dig into now the
history of whether tax cuts help the
economy Donald Trump's tax plan just
released it's a disaster as we've
discussed he wants to cut corporate
taxes from thirty five to fifteen
percent cut individual tax rates get rid
of the alternative minimum tax get rid
of the estate tax so many other things I
recently talked about how if you are a
committed right winger and you're
confused about economics and you think
that tax cuts help the economy then
studies that show otherwise probably
won't change your mind but all I can do
is present you with the facts so let's
give it a shot okay as you can see in
this first image if you're watching on
YouTube or on free speech TV or on our
TV stations with us right now in 1990
George HW Bush raised taxes and GDP
growth increased drastically over the
next five years in 1993 Bill Clinton
further raised the top marginal tax rate
and GDP growth again increased over the
next five years in 2001 george w bush
cut taxes and we saw small rise small
dip small rise small dip in gdp growth
rates when george w bush in 2003 cut tax
rates even more GDP growth tanked
plummeted to a low that we hadn't seen
in a long time gdp growth had almost
zero this was the beginning of the Great
Recession now this isn't evidence that
cutting taxes helps gdp growth or that
raising taxes hurts gdp growth but it
does allow us to deduce that tax cuts
don't in a sort of vacuum in a general
sense help economic growth and there are
of course many many factors in an
economy that impact GDP but what history
shows us and it follows basic logic is
that cutting taxes is not nearly a
surefire way of improving the economy
this was confirmed by one of the most
comprehensive studies that we've had on
whether tax cuts promote economic growth
a 65-year study was conducted by the
Congressional Research Service which is
a nonpartisan government office
published about five years ago over 65
years the study found that top tax rates
are not associated with saving
investment or productivity growth and
the study found that cutting capital
gains taxes and top marginal tax rates
leads to more wealth in equality and
that's obvious why wouldn't that be the
case when rich people are given tax
breaks they mostly pocket the money
because they don't need the money the
money doesn't trickle down and get
spread through the economy in this way
that that a lot of right-wingers supply
siders like to tell us in the 1950s when
the top marginal tax rate was above 90
percent both real GDP and real
per-capita GDP were growing twice as
fast as they are today when the top
marginal tax rate was 35 rather is 35
percent since 1945 the average tax rate
paid by the top tenth of 1% of the
wealthiest people has fallen from 50 to
25% and during that time their share of
income their portion of all income
earned in the United States rose almost
three times from just over four percent
to just over twelve percent this means
what when you cut rich people's taxes
not only do they pay less in taxes
they're able to start earning much more
and wealth inequality gets even worse
this next image shows the tax rates of
the top 0.1% and point oh one percent
they decreased drastically from 1945 to
2009 and compare that to this next image
of how their share of total income
changed hint it went up significantly by
the way this also debunks the right wing
talking point that taxes are higher than
ever so Donald Trump's proposed cuts
will appeal to supply siders it will
maybe
earn him the points he needs with many
Republicans although not all I'll tell
you about that a little bit later
certainly with his friends and his
financial backers but keep in mind and I
know that the committed Trump is doesn't
give a flying you-know-what about the
facts history tells us that cutting
taxes doesn't mean more income for
Americans in general it means that the
rich will get a bigger share of total
income and this is all happening while
Donald Trump continues to propose
cutting crucial government programs is
this the worst tax plan in decades send
me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show I'm coming to you today from
the mass torts made perfect conference
in Las Vegas Nevada much more after this
we reached a new high or a new low
depending on your perspective in the
United States in the growth of income
inequality and the 400 richest Americans
are now paying a lower total tax rate
federal state and local than any other
income group this is based on 2018 data
which has now been analyzed there's a
really good piece in the new york times
by david len art Leonhardt not exactly
sure how he pronounces his last name
about this and when you look at the the
the data and the visualizations of the
data back in 1950 the top 400 richest
americans paid the most in taxes when
you combined federal state and local
fifty years later even in the year 2000
the richest 400 didn't pay the highest
total rates but it was still a much
higher rate than the poor and middle
class you still had the very rich but
not quite as rich as the richest 400
paying slightly higher rates than the
richest 400 but no question that those
richest 400 were paying a higher total
rate federal state and local then lower
income earners and then last year in
2018 the richest 400 actually paid the
lowest total rate of any income group
now you might see that you might hear me
say this and wonder how is that possible
because when you look at the federal tax
brackets for 2018 for example we see
that the tax bracket is
highest at 37% for those earning over
$500,000 but what you need to understand
is that is that we're talking here about
a group the richest 400 that is so far
above the entryway to that top bracket
of 500 thousand that they have so many
different mechanisms for deductions and
loopholes and exclusions and the moving
around of money on paper that they now
are paying the lowest combined federal
state and local rate of any income group
now let's discuss a common argument that
we hear from the american right wing
which is listen whatever rules you pass
whatever tax law you change the rich
will figure out a way to avoid those
taxes so what's the point they'll get
better accountants they will somehow
figure out a way to avoid those taxes
this is completely untrue number one
look at the historical numbers I just
showed you right I mean the rich have
historically not avoided all taxes and
paid the lowest rates they used to pay
more than lower income brackets so
historically we know that that argument
is bogus number two oh and I should
mention we're talking about the very
very rich here we're talking about the
richest 400 the richest 0.1% we are not
talking about a doctor making $300,000
okay that that's not who we're talking
about here and it's important to
understand that there is a distinction
here number two historically attempt to
collect more taxes have worked we know
that when we look at historical tax
collections and number three if the rich
could just avoid any new taxes why would
they work so hard why would they spend
so much time and money and political
capital fighting new taxes because they
know that they would be affected by them
so that argument is a completely bogus
and ridiculous argument these are
basically just choices to be made by
societies and the trick of course by the
very rich and corporations and the upper
class is to foment class warfare down
below this has always been the technique
you hear from some brainwashed
right-wingers that the left of the
middle class and the lower middle class
the poor are the ones fighting and
pushing you know race warfare class
warfare that if it weren't for them then
everything would just be completely fine
but understand that this is a technique
that the very rich use look at the
battle between american-born
restaurant and agricultural workers and
so-called illegals from Latin America
coming here to steal your jobs that is a
battle that corporate America and the
super-rich and the upper class want you
to be having why because if you as an
american-born restaurant worker are
fighting against the idea of some
hard-working Mexican dad coming here to
quote steal your job you are not going
to be fighting the actual people that
are deciding policy and that are
controlling the system and maintaining
the status quo it is by design
another example while the super-rich and
corporate media talk about Millennials
are lazy and this in that it's the
super-rich who win by being ignored
they take the focus off of the fact that
the student loan burden on Millennials
is astronomical they remove any
discussion whatsoever of how the ratio
between the cost of college and the
salary one expects to earn has fallen
completely out of whack compared to what
it was 3040 years ago this is all by
design and it is really important that
we not allow that to distract us from
what actually needs to be done when it
comes to policy because when we're
having the wrong debate they win that's
the the sick genius of it they don't
care who wins these false debates right
if you're a big corporation and you
benefit from cheap labor and
deregulation of labor and all of this
stuff do you care whether the quote
illegals win against the poor
american-born white people in the battle
around who's going to steal whose job no
the fact that it's a battle that is even
going on
means that you win and this is what we
fundamentally have to understand when we
look at these numbers so inequality
certainly getting worse and worse
partially on the back of a tax code that
now has the richest 400 Americans in the
lowest total tax bracket when you
combine federal state and local the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today Justin Elliott who's been a
reporter with Pro Publica since 2012
where he's covered money in politics the
American Red Cross and the Trump
administration recently he's been
covering the taxpayer first act which
we've also been talking about Justin
great to have you on hey good to be here
so for people who don't know what is the
taxpayer first act what what does it do
sure so it's actually kind of like an
omnibus bill that makes a bunch of
changes to the IRS but the thing that
we've been focused on is it it in its
old version it would have put into law a
deal between the IRS and the tax filing
industry basically TurboTax that would
have among other things restricted the
IRS from creating its own sort of
government tax filing system that's
exactly right and we so Richard Neal
who's the congressman here in
Massachusetts has been involved with
this and sort of sadly I mean I like the
guy personally and he was like the first
when I started doing this show the first
sort of real elected official that I
ever met but I'm not particularly
thrilled with his role in this and it's
not necessarily a unique role I mean
this is actually relatively
uncontroversial within some sort of
establishment circles in the House and
Senate that they there seems to be a
sort of you scratch our bracket back
will scratch yours
sort of crony capitalist I mean it's
like the worst of the worst in an area
that a lot of people don't even know is
taking place in a sense yeah I mean so
it gets into this whole whole area of
tax filing and sort of you know the
annual ritual that we all go through of
doing our taxes it turns out that in a
lot of other countries no one really has
to spend hours filling out forms and
doing their taxes and the fundamental
reason for that is that the tax agency
often already has your data so if your
if you're getting paid every couple
weeks and taxes are being automatically
taken out of your paycheck right then
the ir the IRS already has all those
numbers and so in many other countries
they have what's sometimes called return
free tax filing which is basically the
IRS takes all the numbers that already
have pre-populates your return and then
you sort of just look at it and click ok
if it's all good and so the question
becomes well why don't we have that here
and the answer at least part of the
answer is that TurboTax the company that
makes it into it and the rest of the
industry have been lobbying against that
kind of system for at least 20 years at
this point yeah and the so the the way
this works is pretty simple which is if
you make money off of a process that is
perceived as too complicated to do or
actually is too complicated to do
without these pieces of software you're
far more likely to buy one of these
pieces of software and pay the filing
fees now what a lot of people don't know
and correct me if I'm wrong I'm going
off the top of my head if you make under
some certain amount of money a year it
might be in the 60 thousands federal
filing already is free and those
companies like TurboTax provide that
free federal filing but they just don't
make it too easy to figure that out for
yourself you're exactly right so
basically what what has happened is
TurboTax and the rest of the industry
have made this deal with the IRS it's
called Free File and the deal says two
things first it says that the IRS can't
create its own system so the government
can offer you essentially its own
TurboTax or they can't you know create
something like that and in exchange the
industry is supposed to provide free
filing to people this year was making
under sixty six thousand dollars which
turns out to be actually the majority of
the country yeah and then what you
experienced and when you actually go to
choose the version of TurboTax or
whatever that you're going to use it
doesn't it's not made evident that there
is such an option and instead you're
immediately sort of up sold with if you
want to map
some eyes your deductions take advantage
of deduction finder if you have any
Schedule C income or did any sort of
work on the side you should get the
small small and home Business Edition or
something along those lines now what's
important to understand is that that
does not account for the state filing
where correct me if I'm wrong those
costs are actually regulated at the
state level and are not free on the
basis of income it's so it's a whole
sort of complicated patchwork and so
that at the heart of it is as I
mentioned there's this program called
Free File that actually literally most
Americans seventy percent should be able
to use to file at least federally for
free but what what TurboTax Intuit the
company that makes TurboTax has done is
create a separate product that very
confusingly is called just free so free
file and free are different things and
almost no one actually finds the sort of
truly free Free File version because
into it advertises this other version
and if you end up in this quote-unquote
free edition in fact many people will
end up having to pay 100 200 bucks even
though if they had just gone to a
different website it would have actually
truly been free and this is essentially
a significant part of the company's
business model at this point what's the
argument that the government makes for
kneecapping itself on this in other
words we can kind of try to infer what's
going on behind the scenes but what is
this sort of public facing explanation
that the government says we believe in
restricting ourselves in this way you
know that's a really good question I've
actually never heard anyone at the IRS
address that aspect of it I would be
very interested to hear their answer
maybe we've asked them about this what
they will say more generally is that
they support this program because it's a
public-private partnership where the
government instead of having to spend
money on creating its own system and
pulling people will sort of lean on this
already existing private industry that's
that's offering this product for free
which sounds good and might be a good
thing if people were actually using it
but in fact something like 2 or maybe 3
percent of Americans who are eligible
for this free file program actually use
it so virtually no one who's eligible
actually uses it and we've never really
been able to get anyone of the
government to comment on on you know why
those numbers are so low and sort of
what they're thinking is in the program
this seems to me like one of those
things that is really negatively
affected by the way that our election
system works and the way that
appropriating money works because if you
want to it would take longer certainly
would be my guess
than like a term in the house to make
this a reality if the government did
want to develop its own system and
software it might even take longer than
a presidential term and so in the short
term if you want to push this forward
you would have all of these elected
officials who are not actually going to
be around in all likelihood or might not
be around when it actually becomes real
but they have to take the sort of
political hit of saying they want to
spend the money and appropriating the
money and the you know political
football of debt and deficit why bother
right they can just accept contributions
from these industries and keep doing
what they're doing yeah I mean so
there's a there's a couple things going
on so first of all as you know - I mean
Intuit and H&R Block the rest of this
industry are giving a lot of money to
members of Congress of both parties
including Richard Neal there in
Massachusetts who of course is the
chairman of the tax rating committee
Ways and Means Committee in the house
they're also spending millions of
dollars lobbying it's very much of a
sort of bipartisan thing another thing I
would note is that there actually is a
bill in Congress that I believe has been
introduced by Elizabeth Warren and some
others called like the Tax
Simplification Act or something like
that that would that would push the
government in this direction so so there
is legislation out there and the
last thing is that you know I think
you're right that it would be a sort of
heavy lift for first of all for Congress
to appropriate money to the IRS to sort
of create its own system but there is
another option which is the government
could just sort of contract with one of
the companies to create a system and
actually the Pentagon already does this
if you're in the military there's a
whole special military tax filing
service that's just a contract that is
presumably much cheaper when you're
talking about how much money people are
ultimately spending then then individual
consumer is going to like TurboTax calm
that's super interesting it's like
taking Medicare and expanding it to
Medicare for all it's taking the system
that's already in place for members of
the military and saying hey we could
conceivably expand this to include
everybody what else does this Act the
taxpayer first act do outside of what
we've been talking about so far that
maybe is less publicized but important
yeah so there's a whole bundle of sort
of technical and boring changes to the
administration of the IRS one of the
other kind of headline provisions of it
is a and I think this is one of the
reasons why I got a lot of Democratic
support also is that it it restricts
private debt collectors from going after
lower income people who back taxes
essentially which apparently is a
practice that that currently happens
which I didn't know before I started
writing about this and I believe it also
gives some money to a to another tax
prep program volunteer tax prep for
lower compete which is called Vita so
there's a couple things like that but
it's generally you know this bill was
sort of non-controversial
except for this free file provision
which after we started writing about it
and writing about the company's
practices and sort of tricks to get
people away from this truly free version
that provision actually
strip from the bill a week or two ago so
it's it's no longer in there so let's go
back to what you said about debt
collectors and people who owe back taxes
I want to understand exactly what
they're doing the idea is that the debt
collector would target low-income people
who owe back taxes for what exactly do
they fraudulently claimed that they will
help them with their back taxes or are
they taking advantage of people who
might have other outstanding debts on
the basis that knowing they Oh back
taxes they might be more manipulatable
in some way my understanding of it is
that actually the IRS these days used
actually uses private debt collectors to
go after people who you know have not
paid their taxes in some previous year
under some so so they opened so they
owed back taxes and I believe this was
something that this is actually a recent
development the use of private debt
collectors in the last several years so
with this new what this bill does is it
says below a certain income cap we don't
want these private debt collectors going
after people it's something along those
lines although I think the details get
some more technical yeah I mean it's
amazing that so debt collectors and the
debt collection world much like the bail
bonds industry is just rife with abuse
manipulation and all sorts of shady
tactics and even at the base level the
idea that the IRS at all would be using
some of these agencies is a pretty major
concern and red flag to me although I
understand that focusing on low-income
probably makes sense because they're the
most vulnerable and the immediate yeah I
think this is also part of a larger
trend that actually like my colleagues
here at ProPublica and writing about
which is that the IRS you know obviously
no one no one's really excited about the
IRS and probably don't want to you
probably don't want ever personally
interact with the IRS but it's actually
been gutted in recent years the budgets
been cut they've they've had a huge loss
in the number of people that work there
so as a result things like the audit
rate for for the wealthy have has
plummeted you know
corporate tax collections have gone down
so this is my sense is that the the
pride the use of private debt collectors
is is one small part of this larger
story of the IRS just being gutted and
so they they can't do basic functions
anymore it was important to understand
is that that is seen as a feature and
not a bug by those who claim to be about
small government and taking power away
from the government when it comes to
taxation and tax collection it's not
that's not your when I hear you say that
that sounds like a problem but there's a
huge political contingent in this
country that says oh that's good we want
the IRS to be hampered and what it's
able to do yeah that's right and I think
they would argue that you know the
agencies too large and it's it's too
strong we don't we don't want a strong
tax collection agency and this goes back
to you know to at least the 90s when you
you may remember there was a there were
congressional hearings and the mid 90s I
believe about the IRS had sort of gone
out of control and that's kind of the
modern roots of this this whole movement
yep it's been around for a while and it
will sometimes resurface including under
the Obama administration during the
so-called political targeting of on the
basis of the political orientation of
nonprofits for audits which we of course
learned was not what it was made out to
be
Justin Elliott has been a reporter with
Pro Publica
since 2012 he has been covering the
taxpayer first act recently justin great
to talk to you I appreciate your time
thanks a lot the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
the World Economic Forum took place in
Davos over the last few days and a whole
bunch of interesting stuff came out of
it some really really interesting
commentaries about the situation in
Venezuela happened at which we may talk
about a little bit later in the week but
that's not what I want to talk about
today Michael Dell of Dell computers was
asked about his view on this idea
floated by congresswoman Alexandria
Casio Cortez to have a top marginal tax
rate of 70% and Michael Dell not
surprisingly said he doesn't support it
which is totally fine I mean he stands
to be taxed a lot with something like
that but he also claimed that it doesn't
work he actually says tell me someplace
where such a high top marginal tax rate
worked and I'm gonna play the video for
you and it is just so delightful to see
Michael Dell instantly schooled by MIT
professor Eric Erik Brynjolfsson who
explained that hold on a second it
actually has worked in the United States
and this is just so good let's take a
look at the entire moment from the panel
Michael Dell being asked the question
then saying well where has anything like
that worked and then the professor
explains to him well it's actually
worked in the United States where you've
built your business there are growing
calls to address these inequalities that
particularly the wage inequality with
more taxes in particular in the United
States there's been a call by
congresswoman Ocasio Cortes to tax
people earning over 10 million and a 70%
tax rate the current top rate United
States is 37 percent michael doe do you
support this I just want to say I'm
thrilled the dirt Wow
well look I mean you know my wife and I
set up a foundation about 20 years ago
and we would have contributed quite a
bit more than a 70 percent tax rate on
my income on my annual income and I feel
much more comfortable with our ability
as a private foundation to allocate
those funds than I do giving them to the
government all right I'm not supportive
of that and I don't think it would help
the growth of the US economy oh that's
interesting and can you say a little bit
more about why why you don't think I'll
name a country where that's worked ever
United States briefly in the eighties no
no from about the 1930s through about
the 1960s the tax rate averaged about 70
percent at times it was up as high as 95
percent and those were actually pretty
good years for growth so I don't have a
strong opinion on that proposal a lot
but the devil is in the details
but I think it's there's actually a lot
of economics that suggest that it's not
necessarily going to hurt growth yeah so
so let's talk about the facts right
because as Professor Brenda Wilson is
saying there he's not taking a position
on the particular proposal of Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez which I don't even think
rises to the to the level of a proposal
she floated the idea of the seventy
percent top rate didn't even mention at
what tax bracket at what income level it
would kick in it is undeniably true
regardless of what your opinion is of
such a tax policy that the United States
has a long history of high top marginal
tax rates it doesn't mean that the
government takes 70 percent of tons of
people's money it means that very high
earners pay a high marginal tax rate
only on the income they earn above
certain thresholds it's also true that
the US has had many periods of growth
and prosperity and low unemployment
while they also had some of those high
marginal tax rates so it's not
incompatible to have economic prosperity
and
hi top marginal tax rates on very rich
people people with high income that's
not an argument about the morals and
ethics of such a proposal right you
could be for it or against it on a
number of different basis but what we
what we know is that we have had that
type of taxation in the US and it didn't
destroy the economy it's simply true
then you get to part two of the argument
which is that actually we can assess
whether that is a good policy for an
economy to put in place we know that
multiple studies point out that high
marginal tax rates on top earners are
good for the economy if your goal is to
maximize government revenue there are
many studies including one from MIT
among many but the MIT one is one that
we've looked at more closely which says
that 73% is the top marginal tax rate
where you maximize total tax revenue
taking into account that if you go up to
a hundred percent tax rate people stop
working right when you take into account
that other very high numbers can
incentivize people to leave the US and
try to find lower tax places to live or
whatever where you kick in that top tax
rate whether it should be at a million
five million 20 million whatever the
case may be
that is more up for debate and their
different views on it and it is really
easy on this issue to get different
positions confused there's whether we
think it's right morally to take from
the rich okay we can debate that then
you get to the actual economic issues
one is has this worked before the answer
is yes it has I mean quite it it just it
has if the goal is to maximize
government revenue we have some idea
about what that top marginal tax rate
should be and it should probably be in
the low 70s the most popular argument
I've seen lately against such a proposal
is if you do that rich people are going
to leave the country and the government
is going to lose out on all their tax
revenue because they won't be in the US
and they won't be paying taxes here
anymore
that might be the case with some people
but the reality is that first of all if
you move out move out of the US you
don't just stop paying taxes okay a lot
of people don't understand this it's
complicated but if you're a US citizen
who earns much
from a u.s. corporation and you move
abroad you still have to file an
American tax return you still have to
pail to pay taxes you can reduce your
tax liability with things like the
foreign earned income exclusion with the
foreign housing deduction that exists
but most of these American rich people
mostly rich dudes they're not actually
ready to relinquish their US citizenship
assuming that they find another place to
get citizenship which is really the way
to stop paying taxes in the United
States so this wealthy flight horror
story that you hear from the right it's
just not super realistic in large
numbers and it also ignores the fact
that a lot of these rich people have
friends and family mostly in the United
States and even if they could avoid all
American taxes by going elsewhere not
all of them are going to abandon the one
place that they've lived their entire
lives where everyone they know lives so
it's merely a horror story that is not
realistic and it's not a good argument
for tax policy one way or the other but
Michael Dell just schooled in real-time
this is what should be done to Trump and
to sarah huckabee Sanders when they tout
these lies I just love it
so we had a guest not only canceled on
us last minute today but do it in the
rudest way that we've ever experienced
hurling abuse at producer Pat you maybe
someday I will tell the story about what
happened today but it is crazy but the
situation we find ourselves in is that
we were planning on using that interview
today and now we don't have it and we're
not on a deadline so because so many
people are always hoping to call in we
are opening up the phone lines at six
one seven eight three zero forty seven
fifty let's see what is on people's
minds today briefly let's go to Mark
from Newport mark from Newport we
haven't heard from for a while what's
going on mark who David so I had
actually posted about this on your
subreddit but I wanted to try to dig a
little deeper over the phone as possible
so you had mentioned that as opposed to
Elizabeth Warren's wealth tax do
preferred alterations in the way capital
gains are taxed as a means to tax
accumulated capital so as a financial
advisor dr. seems like an inefficient
way to tax accumulated capital which I
really want to so I was just curious
what am I missing
well how would you like to tax it I
would prefer something along the lines
of Elizabeth Warren's wealth tax just
because there's not as many ways that
people like me are required to basically
help people avoid that tax if you read
into her proposal it's pretty much just
every dollar over fifty million armed
with nothing really excluded now I would
be open to the conversation of excluding
certain types of assets from that or if
they're forced to draw assets maybe
avoiding them from other types of
taxation or I don't know I'm open to
that conversation but I just as I think
as a means as to have a broader tax base
to bring in more revenue and just to to
limit wealth inequality I think there's
less room for people like me to help
people avoid paying taxes yeah I mean I
think that you have to balance every
single one of these proposals with the
path to making it a reality and a number
of what seemed to be like pretty good
legal analyses that I've read say that
passing a wealth tax like what she is
proposing whether or not you exclude
certain types of assets would be
extraordinarily difficult and it could
take a decade while it's hung up in
courts so I think there's simpler things
that could be done that would be legally
less complex in order to raise revenue I
mean one of them is and this is usually
thought of merely in terms of the
context of Social Security's viability
but you could raise our income cap on
Social Security from whatever it is now
a hundred and twenty three thousand I
believe to something higher than that
you don't have to put any new
infrastructure in place you're literally
just changing the number by a different
amount than you would by inflation alone
and you immediately generate
significantly more revenue when it comes
to capital gains you are right that
there our whole industry is built around
helping people avoid capital gains
there are also changes that can be made
at the most drastic which would have a
lot of opposition would be taxing
capital gains at the same rate as one's
wage would be taxed based on their
income um that would be but you really
do realize the game I'm sorry what was
that
oh I'm sorry interrupt you still get to
choose we can realize the game and then
you can still like orient your
investment allocation - there's no
question about it it's not a silver
bullet right sure but I think that when
we think you're thinking about all the
right stuff I think that the problem
what we should really think about even
if we like the wealth tax in principle
is the reality that legislatively it
would be extremely difficult that's not
a reason not to think about it it's not
a reason not to do it I just think there
may be lower hanging fruit but it sounds
like you're thinking along the same
lines yeah the bottom line is that is
accumulated capital needs to be taxed so
whatever can get passed pass alright
mark great to hear from you mark from
Newport I was now down the road from you
Narragansett over the weekend oh no way
I lived there when I was in school yeah
you know I didn't love it I have to
admit I didn't it wasn't like the best
place but it was a good weekend all
right mark great to hear from you
appreciate the call
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]